[Musique]
dessiner la mort a demandé la maîtresse
et la plupart des enfants de cette
maternelle une école du 14e
arrondissement de paris choisi au hasard
ont dessiné des avions porteurs de mort
avions de guerre ou détourner la mort
vient du ciel pour ses petits enfants du
siècle de la télévision et des otages
écrire tout ce qui vous passe par la
tête dont la mort a demandé à son tour
le professeur d'une classe de 4e en
milieu rural la mort pour moi c'est
comme un film c'est la fin et toujours
comme dans les films la vie peut se
terminer en queue de poisson ou alors
qu'on n'y comprennent rien du tout et ce
qui est curieux comme dans les films on
s'endort et on ne voit pas la fin on
peut être broyés enseveli écrasé coupé
ciller asphyxié cetera et cetera et
cetera
chez les petits une seconde constatation
ils savent ce qu'est la mort et toi tu
peux mourir
ouais
fait peur non
je pense pas comme vous
comme tout
on n'est pas content et on n'est pas
content et on n'est pas mécontent
c'est triste que ce cas les mots que
j'ai appris vient alors à ce moment-là
qu'est ce qui se passe et après ils
deviennent de la cendre et puis la somme
sans voile s'est fait peur l'aqua de
mourir
oui oui je demandais départ aux dacquois
ce que devenait quand on était mort oui
oui on testera toutefois tu voudrais
leur en poser des questions oui mais
qu'il fallait que j'arrête dix ans pour
comprendre qu'est ce que tu aimerais qu
il te dit comment la somme devient
laquelle couleurs à l'agencé pose des
questions peu nombreux semblent être les
parents qui répondent ou tout simplement
parle de la mort le sujet n'est pas
tabou mais repoussé à 8 9 ans à la
question le vel doigt ceux à qui les
parents ont déjà parlé de la mort 2 doit
seulement se lève dans une classe de
trente enfants
quant aux 10-12 ans cela qu'ils ont déjà
oublié les questions qu'ils se posaient
petit ils se sont fait une raison
d'abord si personne mourrait la terre
serait surpeuplée l'attention populaire
et puis il y aura aucun suspens comment
ça va être
et ça sera une vie monotone complètement
monotone à la télévision les morts que
vous voyez je vous font peur pourquoi
parce que comme c'est ce n'est pas réel
ça ne fait aucun effet et aux
informations des fois ça me passe pas
tout seul
à quoi tu penses et bien aux personnes
qui meurent automatiquement et surtout
désastre que ça peut causer les
personnes politiques par exemple ce
n'est pas seulement une personne qui
meurt mais toute une
démocratie moi j'aimerais bien mourir
mort très rapide pour pas souffrir
par exemple la chaise électrique parce
que je pense qu'on s'ouvre par rapport
par exemple 30 secondes mais pas c'est
fini et je maintiens et je préfère
souffrir beaucoup 30 secondes que
souffrir longtemps pendant six mois et
mourir d'une mort lente et au cimetière
tu voudrais avoir une belle tombe après
la mort bachelot bien et elle en fut pas
moi ya derrière
mais peut-être qu'on sera mort moi
toujours ce que j'ai dit franchement que
je voudrais au lieu d'aller au paradis
j'aurais devenir invisible et revenir
sur la terre on voit comme une vive
après moment mais par an dans le monde
elle est au cinéma sans payer moi je
crois à dieu
alors peut-être imac or grâce à la place
de l'opéra ni est-ce que vos paroles
vous parle de la mort il m'en parle
presque jamais mais ils disent surtout
de faire attention aux accidents par
exemple qu'un char bicyclettes des
choses comme ça parce que ils veulent
pas en parler parce que je suis encore
jeune et j'ai l'avenir devant moi il
faut pas cacher mon avenir en pensant
qu'à la mort
moi je crois que par amber est mort mais
il vit mange pas quoi n'a pas peur de la
mort parce qu'il est et puis il a déjà
assez vécu physique l'avenir derrière
moi et c'est le même prix pour tout le
monde alors tu voudrais mourir tout seul
ou avec quelqu'un tout seul tout seul
sans personne autour de toi parce que ça
me ferait très face parce que c'est
quelqu'un comme on peut pas mourir
ensemble tu voudrais que des parents sur
la côte et toi tu quand tu meures sommes
pas elle ne l'est pas non ça après à mon
enterrement d'accord espace ce que
faisaient nos parents souffrir pour nous
c'est encore pire
[Musique]